hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and according to deadline actor
chewatel egofor has been cast in venom
three but time out isn't he already
mordo in the MCU what's going on here
what character in the Venom Universe
could he be playing let us analyze what
we've seen in the Venom movie so far to
see if we can try to figure it out let's
go speculation Nations ever since Venom
crossed over with the MCU it became part
of that narrative anything is possible
now but what's even more possible is for
you to be styling in these new freaking
nerd riot.shop shirt uh but Guardians of
the Galaxy let's go alright so although
Venom 3 is still in early production
with story details being held close to
the chest we thought it would be fun to
try to make our best educated guess as
to who she would tell egfor could be
playing given what we know about the
Venom verse so far and I can't think of
a better way to start this list off with
the God of all the Symbiotes no himself
the dark reason for the Symbiote season
in venom one we learned that the
Symbiote Riot came to Earth along with
Venom in an attempt to find a role for
their symbiote people to feed on because
we are delicious and the movie of course
ends with Venom and Eddie blowing up
Riot's rocket to prevent a full-scale
alien invasion because they're nice guys
but although Venom and Ryan only
mentioned the Symbiote home planet of
kilintar in passing it very much seems
like both Venom movies are setting up
the audience for an adventure that lets
us explore Venom's Roots especially
given how Venom 2 ended with Venom
trying to teach Eddie about the
multiversal hive mind that connects all
symbiotes together right before he's
interrupted by Doctor Strange's spell we
all have a boss to do you hiding stuff
from me 80 billion light years of Hive
knowledge across universes would explode
your tiny little brain
what what does that even mean
well let me give you a taste then
because while Venom one and two were
mainly meant to show venom exploring
Earth as a new playground Venom 3 will
probably be about any discovering more
about Venom's Homeworld of kilntar
specifically the origins of Venom's
Homeworld and how it came to be and
those Origins are closely tied to the
dark primordial entity no the very old
ass creepy ass man that created the
Symbiote race in the first place null is
truly one of the most powerful Kings of
darkness in the Marvel Comics because
not only did he create the Symbiote hive
mind but before he created Venom species
he was actually the one that forged all
black the necrosaur the weapon Gore the
god butcher wields in both the comics
and the MCU the Symbiotes exist partly
because no lost his neck resort to gore
and was experimenting with a way to
forge new dark weapons to extinguish the
light in the universe having chewatel
egyo4 play the dark God no it would be a
fantastic way to continue Venom's
narrative while also introducing a
massive threat to all the Symbiotes that
Eddie and Venom cannot handle alone
however lucky for Eddie he's not alone
in anymore because if you remember the
ending of Venom 2 had this little fun
moment
imovie's end it appears that detective
Mulligan has acquired his toxin symbiote
like he has in the comics as a result of
Venom and Carnage's Shenanigans are and
if you know anything about toxin from
the Marvel Comics you'd know that much
like movie Venom the toxin symbiote was
very much all about being a lethal
protector it was even training under
Spider-Man at one point in order to
learn how to be the best hero that he
could be a lot of people ask me how I'm
able to stay focused researching all
these videos and honestly it's this
One-Shot energy choose are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everyone really
um
they make Energy Chews and focus choose
the focus choose are my go-to but it
just depends on what you need each
energy chew has 75 milligrams of pure
caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional nootropics to give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew Focus choose
really help me concentrate and give me a
natural boost of energy G with BCD and E
vitamins plus zinc to help with the
immune system support and the amino acid
tyrosine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus that you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order
that's oneshotenergy.com new rockstars
for 10 off so this being the case and
knowing that Eddie Brock has finally
embraced his role as a lethal protector
at the end of Venom 2 it is highly
likely in my opinion that we're going to
see Venom and toxin teen up against a
shared enemy in order to protect the
home planet of their hosts and since
both of these symbiotes are connected
strongly with no Eddie and detective
Mulligan learning to put aside their
past differences and work together to
save the world from Darkness would be a
natural continuation of the Venom story
while also serving as an origin story
where the entire symbiote race but if
she would tell egf4 is not playing no
another character egf4 could potentially
play and knock out of the park is the
Venom verse version of Norman Osborne We
Don't officially know if Norman Osborne
exists in this Venom vs Universe we do
know that early versions of the morbius
trailers did have an Oscorp skyscraper
in them at one point before Sony
inexplicably decided to wipe all traces
of Spider-Man from the movie It's almost
like no way home spell effects of the
trailers too since we also know that
morbius and Venom exist in the same
universe
I know along with other Spider-Man
universe elements like Daily Bugle and
morbius and an astronaut Jameson in
venom one I'm willing to bet a variant
of Oscorp still exists in the venomverse
especially since the oscore building in
the morbius trailers has the same Oscorp
logo from The Amazing Spider-Man 2 but
on a different building and also because
Michael Keaton vulture does appear to be
flying with wings extremely similar to
those that we see in passing in The
Amazing Spider-Man 2 as well and with
Spider-Man freshman year set to
introduce a black Norman Osborne variant
that looks suspiciously similar to chiwa
tell Egypt for him playing Norman
Osborne would be an extremely perfect
fit and finally I cannot in good
conscience and this video without
mentioning the very real possibility
that she would tell eg4 might not be
playing any Sony Marvel character at all
and could just be in venom 3 as MCU
mordo himself because if you remember
the end of Spider-Man no way home while
Venom didn't exactly do much of anything
in MCU 616 he still nonetheless became a
massive threat to that MCU universe and
multi by leaving a little bit of his
symbiote goo behind at the bar and
knowing from the no way home sequel
Multiverse of Madness that both 616 and
A3 versions of mordo are extremely
against a French to the natural law like
Doctor Strange's thanos's and Scarlet
witches I can easily see either one of
those mortal variants coming to arrest
venom for putting the lives of innocent
beings at risk by leaving a piece of
himself behind because remember the
Symbiotes across all the universes are
connected no matter what Universe in the
Multiverse that they are in so Sorcerers
in the MCU probably view symbiotes As
One Singular multiversal threat much
like any one follower of dormammu would
be considered a multiversal threat due
to the multiversal dormammu's influence
like they're connected to a multiversal
beings but therefore each one of them
are a multiversal threat the mordo from
the 8th rate universe that we met in
Doctor Strange 2 is the most likely to
be the one to arrest Venom due to his
ties to the Illuminati and their
multiversal knowledge and Endeavors and
since he is the only member of the
Illuminati left alive after Doctor
Strange 2 so I can honestly see 8-38
mordo founding a new Illuminati Council
of just mortal variants so they can go
around the Multiverse correcting
Abominations to the Natural laws like
Venom and Doctor Strange and maybe even
Peter Parker after that's done he pulled
that apparently sent people to the wrong
universes but yes those are who I
believe she would tell eg4 could be
playing in venom 3. I really hope that
he's going to be Norman Osborne or mordo
or both because I feel like those are
just the most exciting casting choices
but who do you want you to tell
egforward to be cast as in venom 3 let
us know in the comment section below but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
masterton on Twitter if you guys want to
see me tweet some weird I love you
guys times 3 000 and I'll see you guys
next time hi